is june 19th juneteenth the federal  holiday marks the emancipation of slaves  this weekend a major juneteenth  celebration is being held over at the  world market expo center downtown  organizers say juneteenth is more than  just a fun celebration it's about  recognizing history and embracing  diversity  juneteenth means unity  it means unity and just like you said  everybody's coming together it's not  just one particular group it's for  everybody so many years people talked  about juneteenth but not many people  understood and represented of what it is  and also it was sort of in the  background now it's in the forefront and  i just love it  the event over at the expo center is  free it's from five to nine saturday  evening